foreign
[Applause]
with my bestie Cameron Diaz it's like
real life right now and uh she's gonna
show us how to make literally something
that none of us ever want to come over
to the house without it being prepared
or watch you make it the only reason you
guys come over is it I mean well it's
just it's so exciting to like show
people something that we're all so
attached to it's very we are very
attached to this all right this can go
with any meal ladies and gentlemen this
is Cameron's famous shallot gold so the
oil needs to be hot enough it shallots
it's full of water you just need to like
cook it down like on a high heat and get
all the water out of it see I don't
think like that you don't it's chemistry
like this kind of stuff like with
vegetables and onions and stuff
that's why we all have our Specialties
it's it's science I
did you learn that like in like high
school in Long Beach no I didn't I mean
I didn't learn anything in high school
in Long Beach
but what I did learn is that she had fun
but I had fun
um the thing about you're a cheerleader
I wasn't a cheerleader I was on the
drill team I've seen that's right you're
in a universe that's the drill team oh I
was terrible at it
the missteps of it yeah we wouldn't even
do a Charlie's Angels that didn't have
big dance numbers with you in it because
you're the best dancer but I was really
bad at like walking with a flag and
counting my steps in the making of a
left turn
I'm making it like I'd run into people
I'm like oh I'm sorry I went the wrong
way it's so bad I could see that what
you want is you need this to be very
um
you know you're just cooking it down
basically shallots being
um watery watery it's chemistry it's
chemistry
and those are sugars that are being
released as they get heated and the best
way to kind of like speed that up and to
make the most out of those sugars as
they're getting cooked with heat is to
put salts on them okay so sugar I like
the I see see and also like this is an
electric stove you know what I
understand better yeah I understand fire
yeah you're right yeah you're the real
deal can I just talk about your old uh
kitchen and hot up at croissants that's
exactly what I'm talking about
yeah she had her her curse on was
psychotic
it's like the worst kitchen to cook in I
mean I've cooked in like hundreds of
kitchens this one was like I it was a
phenomenon like it was the craziest
thing I've ever seen I I your friend you
brought your friend Gwyneth Paltrow over
and she said about my oven and I quote
you're breaking my heart
there's nothing like Gwyneth Paltrow
coming to your kitchen and saying you're
breaking my heart I was like it was
rough see how these guys are going now
they look cool they're getting gold
they're not supposed to goal but these
are those are gold so the end product is
this situation okay now
the oil is also gold
you gotta save the oil
I lost it enough I love
to accident we were watching gold member
um I do you remember when we went
skydiving I yes of course it was
literally the only time I've ever skated
it me too yeah when
yeah yeah
we were really
I think it was I think it was like that
was our time of life like in life we
were just jumping out of airplanes like
it was like a free fall I'm in that time
in life we literally were so free we
would Skydive we would scuba dive with
sharks remember that with sharks in
Tahiti yes yes we scuba done with sharks
and Tahiti I was the first into the
water yes you were right in with the
sharks and then we get under there and
the guy's like here's how you
communicate and then he teaches us how
to communicate underwater Brian thank
you very much then we all get under the
water and then out of nowhere like a
horror movie he whips out this giant bag
of blood two nachos yeah and he Chums
the water and before you know it there
are more sharks than you could ever
imagine but like that's how we rolled
yeah that's and then I remember I was
like
kind of just kicking along and all of a
sudden I like turn around and the
shark's like right behind me and he's
like what I wasn't that with me that
wasn't me I wasn't doing anything and
then I'd be like okay and I'd swim in
here and I'd be like and he'd be like
what what me what me well thank God
because what's to make them not be like
you know what you look like a snack
animals you are a snack by the way will
you tell everybody
about avalene because yes honestly these
incredible products you're so
knowledgeable speaking of chemistry Bill
Nye the Science Guy over here literally
you taught me something that I didn't
know about wine did anyone here know
that wine a lot of wine does not tend to
be vegan
like that was one of those aha moments
of like oh my gosh even that there's
over 73 ingredients that can be added to
wine without any you know disclosure
from the winemaker so that was what
brought you know my partner Catherine
power and I to kind of make these this
this wine because we wanted to drink
wine that we knew how it was made what
was in the bottle what wasn't in the
bottle
and we wanted to be able to share it
with those consumers that hold the same
values as we do
[Applause]
are you ready to rip into some roast
chicken I am so excited oh wait here
hold on yeah I have utensils in here
um Can I taste it see Jose
oh my God oh my God
which would you pair today with the
roast chicken I don't know I might be
the red well thank you poo poo thank you
poo poo once again I just I don't know
when your best friend when you get to
hang out with your best friend life is
good and I know everything makes sense
you can pick up your own bottle of
Cameron's wine avalene it is 100 organic
and vegan and no unwanted additives it
is the perfect wine with any meal any
meal or with any occasion yeah exactly
really just one of those things you can
work into fold into your lifestyle you
don't need food
we'll be right back
[Music]
foreign
[Music]